hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play and and this
is slightly terrifying okay I saw the
review of this game online and there
wasn't a whole lot to it um except for
the fact of the world is being destroyed
by this giant giant thing in the sky and
it really wants to suck up the entire
environment okay so um it's a very
simple game it's very simply made but
I'm supposed to survive for 6 minutes
and I'm guessing Devon comes when you
either touch that beam or fall through
the cracks because it's literally
sucking up the world okay
and these green dots you can see in the
top left because my face is on the other
side right now that there are these
things called survive eating tack and
wool my what the hell is going on that
didn't even do anything how did that
happen okay so the yellow thing gives
tack and the green thing gives food if I
run out of food I lose if I run out of
know if I only run out of food I don't
know I'm kind of trying to keep my
excuse me I'm trying to keep my
composure as the world is ending here
okay so it shouldn't be too hard I mean
I thought there was a gap there I mean
if I just stay out of the way I should
be fine right I need to keep moving
around to get food that's kind of one of
the things that keeps me from just
camping off in a corner and that little
sphere you can see him he's messing up
the world but he's also throwing food
around
yeah Andy's throwing the tech thing and
the tech thing I believe it okay all
right this is good oh okay
ah ha ha ha ha ha ha ha it allows you to
jump higher which helps if there's a
giant gap in the middle of nowhere
hey hey hey hey hey hey give me give me
the damn foot did I get it ok I got it
I can't even see where the thing is
dropping off things anymore I think this
one over there huh
ah no it's falling oh no no no no thank
you thank you thank you for your
contribution to the markiplier Hunger
Fund I'm just go my god what the hell is
going on here the world is ending I
guess I was an apt description of what
the hell's going on hey you tell you why
you [ __ ] you stay away from me or
Gabbar doesn't want anything to do with
you it's got nerve wracking okay there's
a little bit of calm over here I'll try
to stay out of the way apparently you
need a lot a lot of food to survive so I
got a key phone AHA delicious oh hi
how'd you get over here wait is there
more than one of you which goddammit
about food odd okay good
thank you for your contribution to the
markiplier fund okay sorry I'm it's
getting a little tense
I might actually bigger ones go down
what the hell what happened did you drop
a food right in the gap you [ __ ]
ah come on okay you
where you going where you going no
hahaha oh I made it okay
I made it I'm okay I'm okay okay I get
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] okay
more tack over there I can jump even
higher up well come on come on don't
mess up don't mess up don't mess up yeah
Oh No the mouse is going outside of the
screen I think I don't have to click
anywhere
this is mildly terrifying God if I was
really on this platform I would be
panicking out of my butt more tech for
tech ah ah ah food the food keeps
falling how am I supposed to survive if
the food keeps falling down well I can
jump really high now come back here you
bastard you but stabbing bastard I'm
gonna kill him ah food okay and now I
have more food than survive time what
does that mean I do not know okay
oh it's getting hard to navigate I gotta
make it yeah yeah oh yeah I can jump
really high no no but yeah more oh no no
no no no yes No maybe so can I get the
who did I get it I don't know if I
actually got it did I get it the mouse
keeps going outside of the screen Oh God
death suit devastation ah oh no no aah
come on any more food ah come on any
more food oh it's all the way over there
the hell how am I supposed to be able to
I need more food ah oh god no
oh no oh my god food no no no no aah
come on all right i'ma try this again
god damn it a height I guess I shouldn't
have talked so much in the beginning I
should have stockpiled on food yeah
damn it I was so close I was so close
did I get that so V stockpile on food it
won't be as much of a problem later
oh these dick bags and AK holes oh man
hey do you like to mess with me I miss
my super jump but can't I super jump
give me more tech you douche don't give
me more food I want tech aha so there
are more than one EW I saw two yoo-hoos
at the same
okay soft echo ver here somewhere there
it is
yay in the valley of the shadow of death
deep in the shadow of my balls hey get
out here with your pillory silliness
yeah that is an ominous noise by the by
it doesn't have to say okay food over
there is it just me or am i running out
of food a lot quicker now what's the
deal what's the dealio okay so I just
got a house so close
I was so close I only needed to survive
for six minutes I was like at 5:30 come
on just your God uh it's slightly slide
II I hate it when things are slidy
slighty and slippery all over where to
go where to go where to go that's not
the same one where to go ah the mouse
okay got it now you give me your damn
thing
all right okay ah I need more tack where
the hell is all the tack you give me
your damn tech robot smash you in the
balls no I wouldn't is where you are a
ball so I guess smashing you in the face
would be equivalent to smashing you in
the balls yeah I don't hate that big
pillar I hate you give me the damn tack
we're the damn tack where's that sound
check - yes yes yes I want the tech oh
this one's nestled in - nothing to say
thank you thank you thank you right
god damn it I need so much food I have
no tack where's the tack
give me that damn tack won't give me the
tech guys where's the tech I found lots
of tech before I don't even really know
what tech is it's just generic deck for
tech eNOS yeah get out there no care
anymore no carry I'll make it through
with one tack I think for some reason
when I add more tack before it made me
God now I'm saying tech so much it ah no
oh
I made it I made it I survived ha ha ha
oh my god
that's too close oh thank goodness that
one pillar was sticking out for me
Oh God but I'm gonna starve cuz I don't
have enough tack I'm saying the word
tack so much it doesn't even sound like
tack anymore doesn't even sound like
English tack if you say any word in the
bow not God
Pierce balls ass [ __ ] dick this games
hard it's gets hard
all right I'm right now one more time
let's dude hey why are you doing I see
that over there all right one more time
one more time I see tech cuz one I saw
tech pretty good okay
food food where's the tech your tech
give me the damn tech give me the damn
food it's so hard to pick up things stop
spitting out food give me ten
yeah why don't we Noatak my food but
food food for you but come on ah hi ah
oh is that what keeps happening it keeps
stuff oh my you keep stopping to deliver
tack and then the tap no my beautiful
jack okay I just got to keep an eye on
it and then go where it needs me to go
okay you I I see you
where'd you go where'd you go you [ __ ]
oh oh oh I see you I see you give me
your fine I'll take your food I need it
anyway because I'm about to starve to
death apparently where'd you go there's
more food but I'm coming after you you
drop your tech you drop your tech you
[ __ ] for such a simple game very low
res low graphic it's actually quite
interesting
the gameplay is awfully fun in my
opinion it just my humble love it I am a
Cho my humble opinion this is actually a
pretty fun game you also tried totally
free ah
come back here very small it's like 8
megabyte tiny download for a 3d game
come back here give me some tack how
about you give it you tack would you
like to give me some tech I'd like it if
he gave me some tech no I didn't even
see that one that was my bad fine you
know what whatever I'm done with you I'm
done with you you [ __ ] so if you guys
want to beat my high score by actually
beating the game go right ahead link to
the game is in the description below
hope you enjoyed it I might actually
play this on my own pro by the way thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video